[Music]
all right Randy
I did not want to see you outside of the
house until Sunday I mean - when did you
know this is it I mean pretty much when
Ross told me that he was picking Marissa
over me I knew that I didn't have a
chance
all right now you just stepped outside
the house James went out right after you
so happy
I literally screamed I heard I was like
oh so happy he's a goodbye message to
you not the friendliest I don't care I
am
you said you filmed one that was worse
for him I think so what was it can give
us a piece of what it was no I mean
honestly I was angry in the moment so
I'm just trying to be positive and look
forward and not backwards okay now
there's still a lot of people in that
house and there's only two days left in
this condition right now if you had to
call it who's gonna win I'm hoping that
Ariana wins and I think that she has a
great chance she's 24 she's smart she's
athletic um and she's a great soul she's
such a good girl
yeah you guys really bonded in there and
she got on your friend for life for sure
I mean definitely gonna keep you in
contact with a lot of the people from in
there I really you grow close and you're
you know living with someone 24/7 yes
Ross Marissa meta for sure hopefully
maybe Omarosa I feel like I like her
which is odd but um Chuck I love
obviously I didn't want to get really
love Cher I liked most people I just
didn't love mark I didn't like James at
all right yeah oboro-sama shocked kind
of the world you ever gotten to see the
reaction to it but she's said a lot of
stuff we're seeing kind of a new Omarosa
when she was saying all this stuff in
the house what was going through your
mind about her time in the White House I
told her to be careful I said your boss
is known for saying he's gonna sue
people and I just got out of lawsuit so
you might want to check yourself but it
was so interesting and she's so
intelligent and I just want to sit and
have lunch with her and hear it all
you know everybody got messages from
home your message didn't come from home
Wow I came from Bravo headquarters yes
you saw Andy pop up on the screen what
went through your mind I mean I was I
love Andy we're friends we've known each
other for so long he gave me my first
job on TV I mean we go way back and I
was shocked to see him I didn't expect
it and it was great it was such a nice
message well you know what kind of
started an online campaign people were
like hashtag giver for Diamondback Oh
would you ever go back and do that show
again yes of course that's like my home
I feel at home with all of those crazy
women even the one we won't say all
right moving forward what is next for
you what's the first thing you're doing
when you're getting out of these dorms
going straight to my ex's house and
picking up Mike
[Music]